alors je vous avertis sont un peu
déchaînés et dissiper ce soir alec
castonguay chantal hébert michel c'est
au gérant soir à vous trois soirs même
campagne
oui c'est votre dernier alors ce sens
pour ça vous vous laissez aller un peu
ce soir
écoutez il ya plein de thèmes abordés on
va commencer ce souhaite évidemment avec
ce qui a marqué la campagne libérale
d'une espèce de culo de messieurs qui
viennent de tomber sur la tête alors ces
jo chantal qui dit des jeunes la
grosseur de la main sur wii après avoir
entendu le genre des changes que ça a
donné donc des attaques avec un exemple
et de la défense aussi avec monsieur
trudeau on écoute ça gal gilles comme
lobbyiste pour transcanada en était le
président est le coprésident de la
campagne électorale de justin trudeau et
des libéraux ont je pense là que
monsieur trudeau doit prendre une
décision rapidement et dire que ce
monsieur gagné ne doit plus rester à la
tête de sa campagne qui le congédie
monsieur gagné n'a jamais contribué à
nos politiques énergétiques
on savait que en tant que bénévole il
avait des clients de toutes sortes de
différentes secteur et donc on a
toujours on a toujours gardé à l'écart
de nos décisions peu en termes de
politique énergétique
alors la ligne d'attaqué revenait
essentiellement aujourd'hui de la part
des adversaires de monsieur trudeau
c'était voici ici ressurgir le vieux
parti libéral évidemment tout de suite
on évoque tous les scandales scandale
des commandites petit massue jambes un
petit nation on a un premier ministre
chef conservateur et premier ministre
sortant qui assure véhicule une semaine
encore où on a expliqué l'ancien manques
il y avait nommé des gens qui sont
livrés à des abus de dépenses au sénat
mais que en plus une opération de
camouflage au plus haut niveau de son
gouvernement
alors mes petites fm n'a su à cause du
moment
c'est comme quand on achète une maison
de location location location
on est en fin de campagne la fin de
semaine va se passer dans les bilans et
les décisions éditoriales des uns et des
autres donc c'est une histoire qui va
vendre des limites et je suis convaincu
les libéraux en sont fort soulagé parce
que c'est vraiment pas jean decool qu'on
veut à n'importe quel moment dans une
campagne
moi je pense que ça va le désavantage
prochain très douce et que sa frappe là
où ça fait mal c'est à dire qu'on a
beaucoup véhiculer l'image de changement
juste entre nous
incarnez ça même pour essayer de battre
thomas moquer avec un certain succès
c'est lui qui pour l'instant est en
avance dans les sondages
et là on se retrouve avec effectivement
des apparatchiks libéraux qui ont de la
ram à jouer de la vieille politique
c'est à dire donner des conseils à une
entreprise privée alors que sa propre
équipe des chances d'accéder au pouvoir
de me le gagnant d'un donneur et des
conseils et à la pétrolière ne vais pas
c'est juste être doc et des chances
d'être premier ministre et sa pauvre
équipe qui va être le donc sa part m
haies salades et de levier politique
alors incarner le changement quand suite
d'une note encore derrière toi des gens
qui font ce type de manoeuvre là ça
contredit le message qu'on passe depuis
un bon moment
effectivement quelques jours de
l'élection c'est certainement pas
quelque chose de positif la meilleure
chose pour justifier que ça arrive
justement ce moment ci étant lundi
dernier c'est arrivé lundi dernier une
semaine là dessus et c'est un fait que
c'est quand même pas rien
le monsieur devant même jusqu'à dire et
puis dani alves est pas non plus
n'importe qui en politique de l'ancien
chef de cabinet de 3 au premier ministre
c'est parce que c'est pas rien et que ça
veut dire vous savez le cabinet sera
plus petits à peu près 25 personnes donc
le ministre des finances soit plus
important que d'habitude ça ça s'appelle
données du conseil stratégique ça ça
fait très mauvaise bouche quand ça vient
de l'intérieur comme ça puis dire après
sinistre c'est un bénévole
oui était sans doute pour payer 8 et co
président de la
campagne cela dit les faits limité à
cause du moment où ça arrive moi je
regardais ce qui est bien dans ce
courrier la jeune fille est de gagner
j'ai découvert quand il était chef de
cabinet des bonnes personnes dans les
années 80 ça donne une idée et j'ai
regardé ce qu il ya de l'acquis
franchement si quelqu'un pays pour ce
genre de conseils là il ya de l'argent
qui se gaspille ces championnats et je
me suis dit mais qu'est ce qui a bien pu
passer par de saïx de monsieur gagné
d'écrire un courriel comme ça ce qu'ils
sont dans un peu c'est qu'au moins il me
prend trop de parler d'un conseil des
ministres à 25 dans le cas du npd ou des
libéraux dont il n'ya pas organiser un
rendez vous avec un ministre des
finances qui connaît pas encore nous
sommes un petit peu moins a dit le
billet se passe peu plus oui ça marche
comme étant donné qu'ils conseillent
aussi inutiles et probablement été
préférable qu'ils s'attachent les doigts
et il ya un autre problème c'est de la
réaction du parti libéral assure tempête
la sadec r on a passé plusieurs heures à
défendre daniel ghani à dire dans le
fond tout était légal n'avait pas
enfreint aucune règle à pression et
c'est la faute aux conservateurs qui
répondent à des attaques personnelles
finalement en fin de journée c'est lui
même qui est bien connu quand je prends
du recul je me retire la campagne est là
aujourd'hui justin trudeau dit c'est
inapproprié au point où il n'occupera
plus de fonctions à long terme au parti
libéral il est donc passé en quelques
heures de quelque chose d'acceptable à
l'exil du parti libéral du canada pour
plusieurs années sa santé
l'improvisation ans en allant qui sont
non plus c'est pas quelque chose qui
pousse mais ici pas c'est quand même
quelque chose aujourd'hui pendant que
justin trudeau est interrogé là-dessus
par les journalistes on a vu un justin
trudeau hâtivement en colère très ferme
que rappeler à l'ordre ses militants
vous regardez justement comment ça s'est
passé
et ceux-là on n'est pas habitué de voir
ça quand même message je ne suis pas si
le rappeur s'était vainement un peu
facile point de presse systématiquement
tout ce qu'ils ont ils font tous et
c'est une pratique que tous les
journalistes s'entendent pour dire
qu'aucun devrait faire jaser mais
stephen harper c'est systématique et ça
a souvent donné lieu à des moments assez
désagréable et c'est pas stephen harper
lui-même mais à la décharge de son
équipe qui est quand même arrivé
fréquemment que les membres de son
équipe en feutre des militants aussi
donc mais il ya une solution à cela
c'est faire des travaux du fisc alors
qu'avec les militants comme décor c'est
ça changer l'image de fond financier non
l'image que je vais vous montrer mon jeu
les en petits si on veut la mettre à
l'écran maintenant alors c'est la carte
du québec
regardez longval a détaillé un petit peu
alors voyez npd un allemand sherbrooke
c'est le parcours aujourd'hui de touba
volcan voyez ici pour parti conservateur
alors trois rivières drummondville
thurman le dos va se faire dans les
villes de québec ce soir
voyez bloc québécois alors lâché ce giro
mascouche et finalement en rouge
justin trudeau libéral s'intéresse laval
ça se termine en ce moment à outremont à
montréal
alors quand vous regardez le parcours
des chefs aujourd'hui ce trajet le
qu'est ce qu'elle lui dit cette carte là
elle me dit qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
batailles au québec qui sont fort
intéressantes pas nécessairement celle
qu'on veut nous faire croire par exemple
ça faisait que des fonds se promène dans
des comtés où qu'on veut conserver parce
qu'on apprenne les pertes d'autres fois
il en est qui sont à l'offensive qui
essaie d'aller chercher des comptes et
ne veut pas au québec il ya quand même
78 sièges on a beaucoup parlé de
l'ontario et les chefs vont y retourner
dans les prochains jours en ontario ils
vont probablement finir la campagne là
mais il reste encore des batailles au
québec fois intéressante assez pour que
les chefs par canadiens soient obligés
de se déplacer que venir ici encore
parlé une dernière fois aux lecteurs
pensent que je n'ai pas couvert de
campagne
fédérale où il est autant de batailles
entre des partis différents ça c'est
évident mais au québec où c'était aussi
difficile de dire on va faire une courte
liste de bataille intéressante parce que
la lire ce système est trop longue
c'est pas le cas d'habitude d'habitude
on dit bon mais ça ça va être libéralisé
soixantaine d'autres qui ont parlé à
d'autres choses mais là ce que ça vous
dit
c'est que tout le monde espère et
beaucoup d'espoir un trajet de monsieur
harper aujourd'hui et bien drummondville
pour les rappeler malheureusement basso
c'est là que j'ai déjà dit que c'est
terminé c'est certain il y avait les pas
loin là où il va le faire des gains ça
fait plusieurs élections fédérales que
je couvre la première à 79 mais je n'ai
jamais vu le québec aussi divisé en
plusieurs parties
d'habitude le québec à un moment donné
dit on s'en voit quelque part et pas mal
tout le monde suit il ya eu des vagues
la vague de moroni la vague de trudeau
avance à la vague du chien ou chat live
orange
les québécois et le bloc avant de
choisir mais c'est quand même un peu
plus en fin de cycle c'est la première
fois que je vois le bloc gaza quatre
airs où il ya des gens qui s'envole de
chacun des côtés alors l'expression
anglaise qui explique ma maison ils sont
partout sur la carte le lycée compris on
a tant de gens essayer d'analyser ce à
dire ah ils vont dans les endroits où
ils risquent de faire des gains d'autres
non non ils vont dans les endroits où
ces livres ont appuyé nos niveaux
parce que si on serait déjà universelle
en ontario cette semaine c'est clair
monsieur harper défendez du terrain qui
craint de perdre dans ce cas aussi
meurent quand jack layton va cherbourg
qui défend un siège quand iba allemand
c'était un peu de repos il doit être
facile mais dont il va parce qu'il pense
qu'il veut le garder si elle n'est pas
allemands pour attaquer le ministre
lebel gars de la région et monsieur
trouvait dos il va se promener dans
outremont pourquoi pour faire mal mais
pas plus gros que le début de la
campagne quand les néo-démocrates se
promenait avec des sondages dans leur
poche les regards et on va perdre
d'autres un papillon et c'est un message
de confiance qu'il avait aujourd'hui
monsieur dans lequel on vole on entend
justement là-dessus
moi je me souviendrai toujours qu'en
on m'avait dit que outremont était une
forteresse libérale imprenable
j'ai l'habitude de provoquer des
surprises dans des forteresses libérales
est prenable et les forteresse bloquiste
imprenable et des forteresses
conservatrice imprenable alors c'est un
peu rien italia c'est tout sauf de mai
mais la réalité c'est que celui de toute
façon qui risque le plus de perdre des
côtés l'une soit c'est lui c'est thomas
mulcair parce que il ya un autre ont
littéralement je serai les ragots donné
l'aval de leurs prêts il ya des comptes
et majin au npd compte normalement on
pénible pouvait pas penser gagner qu'ils
ont gagné à cette vague là jusqu'en
gaspésie je te donne dans d'autres
endroits
c'est clair ils vont perdre un certain
nombre les autres à sedan guerrier sur
le ring c'est utile afin de voir le
drame vraiment aidé sais pas ce qui se
passe au québec où ils vont quand même
conservé hier
un nombre de sièges au parti qu'il est
censé ne pas avoir réussi à percer en
ontario où là il n'y a pas un chantage
qui leur montre qu'ils sont bons envers
les gays qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé quand les gens ont vu de l'ontario
est resté marqué par bas bruit les
années 90 mais aussi quand les gens ont
vu que justin trudeau se tenait debout
comme cheikh qui faisaient une campagne
où il n'avait pas l'air dominateurs ils
ce sont des douanes et de l'obligation
de penser à voter mais npd voilà la
stratégie qui est important et au québec
et en ontario en ontario plus rapidement
il s'est imposé comme étant justin
trudeau
les sondages étaient bons pour lui les
20 minutes on touille énormément sièges
seulement une lutte libérale
conservatrice à la clé un [ __ ] c'est
davantage dans le sud de l'ontario dont
ses yeux de l avantage puisque c'est le
porter dans les sondages à la ramener
dans les sondage pancanadien un niveau
assez élevé qu'influencer d'autres
provinces ou si ceci dit ce qui avantage
le npd au québec par rapport à l'ontario
c'est le vote francophone parce qu'on
parle toujours de course serrée entre le
npd et les libéraux
il reste en avance par 10 12 points les
[ __ ] chez les francophones y comme la
majorité des circonscriptions le vote
francophone est très important ça va
l'aider à garder des siennes chez la
raison il va en perdre plusieurs mais ça
sera pas une débandade de terre à moins
d'une surprise en fin de semaine du côté
du npd parce que son vote francophone
tient quand même l'avouer un mot sur un
monsieur emprunt sur une stratégie de
communication qui l'utilisent depuis le
début de la semaine et qu'il trimballe
d'un bout du pays avec lui alors
mesdames messieurs c'est sûr que vous
l'avez vu quand on entend un son de
caisses enregistreuses et que là on
choisit quelqu'un leurs en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui c'est ton père de famille de
quatre enfants trois rivières mais on a
vu des mères de famille on en a vu
d'autres alors on balance des tonnes
d'argent
un peu comme dans un jeu télévisé la
leur aux balances des tonnes d'argent
comme ça avec ce bruit qui cling cling 5
nous sommes tous surpris la première
fois qu'on a vu ça mais là de voir que
c'est répéter tous les jours c'est à
dire qu'ils sont convaincus que sa porte
ça marche on en parle son nom ça fait ça
fait guère de doute
on se rappellera stockwell day quand il
était chef de l'alliance canadienne à la
sortie un petit carton à la fin du
dernier débat qui faisait
pas de disparition de medicare il y
avait passé pour quelqu'un qui n'était
même pas des astuces
je suis pas convaincu totalement écouter
au point où en est la campagne de
monsieur harper toujours possible il
s'en va en fin de semaine participez en
grand la ligue dont les frères ford le
meilleur celui qui est connu sur toute
la planète et qui n'est plus maire pour
ceux qui sont au courant et son frère
qui se promène partout mais au même
moment aujourd'hui un moment surréaliste
le frère d'europe poule il s'est
retrouvé d'abord en difficulté parce
qu'ils avaient été filmés en train de
prendre ce cra audi il faut pas voter
pour justin trudeau parce que déjà fumé
un joint
trouvez l'erreur mais si ça se dit si
une porte mais ça je sais qu'ils ont
encore l'impression que ça peut marcher
c'est qui encore un public pour ça c'est
encore une tentative désespérée sexy la
campagne conservatrice elle est vieille
de mandrin mandat majoritaire stable
malgré tout leurs partenaires
transpacifique denis baisses d'impôts
qui devient dans les dernières années et
pas des petites mises en scène pour
attaquer les libéraux ce que ça montre
que ces libéraux qui sont en avance et
qui essaie de ramener sa base qui est
lauper effectivement des hausses
d'impôts qui est avec la foundation
europe forte dans les banlieues toronto
a demandé une campagne qui va mal ça se
sent on essaie de mise en scène
achetez des gens qui vont trouver ça
intéressant peut-être est-ce que ça veut
dire que ça vaut bien un jour en suisse
que c'est ça là-bas il faut sortir la
danse bien sûr qu'ils ne décident pas de
rester à maison lundi mais c'est
finalement les conservateurs pour fait
une belle campagne je reste à la maison
ça risque de les mobiliser en même temps
si on voyait par exemple vendu qu'à
faire le tour seulement des dessins des
salles de syndicats dont sud de
l'ontario on dirait ça va pas vraiment
bien son affaire des gants chaussures je
sais c'est qu'une non campagne pour eux
mais ça l'est aussi pour vous et vous
serez quoi là avec nous demain vous
allez participer chacun à votre façon
soirée électorale ne le dit vous avez un
problème de gorge michel voir ça s'est
passé
merci à vous trois merci au revoir